just breaking away now going live to
Scotland where Nicola Sturgeon
Scotland's first minister of course
leader the SNP is giving a news briefing
in this very room just over a month ago
I could not reasonably have hoped for a
more emphatic victory in this election
last night the SNP won an incredible 80%
of seats in Scotland an overwhelming
endorsement of our campaign message and
vision it is clear beyond any doubt that
the kind of future desired by the
majority in Scotland is very different
to that chosen by much of the rest of
the UK Scotland has rejected Boris
Johnson and the Tories and yet again we
have said no to breaks it during this
campaign
I said repeatedly that all elections are
important of course they are but that
this one really mattered I said that the
very future of Scotland was on the line
last night was indeed a watershed moment
so today as we reflect on the outcome we
should also look ahead this morning I
want to address both the people of
Scotland and the Prime Minister directly
to the people of Scotland I want to see
a simple but heartfelt thank you thank
you for the overwhelming victory
you gave the SNP last night the SNP will
never ever take you for granted we will
continue to work every single day to
earn your trust however you voted last
night both in government at Holyrood and
in opposition at Westminster we will
focus relentlessly on building a fairer
and a more prosperous country for
everyone who lives here we will continue
to promote
outward-looking internationalist values
that are so firmly at the heart of the
SMPS vision for scotland and we will do
whatever we can to protect Scotland from
what I fear will be a deeply damaging
Tooley government that means we will
stand firm in our defence of our
National Health Service we will resist
to the very best of our ability the
ultra brexit Tory ideology that
threatens our race to the bottom on
issues like Environmental Protection's
Food Standards and what crude rates and
we will stand up for the rights of those
from other European countries who have
chosen to live here and I want to
briefly address them directly today - I
am very aware that for you this may be
the most difficult day since the morning
after the break sit vote so let me see
this again and from my heart you are
welcome here we value your contribution
and I will fight with everything I have
to protect you right to call Scotland
your home now of course elections can be
invigorating but also bruising events so
let me congratulate all those candidates
last night who won but also commiserate
with those who lost seats
despite the hard-fought nature of this
election campaign I believe and I hope
that we can in Scotland know agree on
two fundamental points firstly it is now
clear beyond any doubt that the
overwhelming majority of people in
Scotland do want to remain in the
European Union that verdict was first
delivered in the referendum in 2016 it
was reinforced in the general election
of 2017 it was strengthened in the
European election earlier this year and
last night it was emphatically confirmed
Westminster has ignored people in
Scotland for more than three years last
night the people of Scotland said enough
it is time for Boris Johnson to start
listening
I accept regretfully that he has a
mandate for brexit in England but he has
no mandate whatsoever to take Scotland
out of the European Union if he presses
ahead he will drive a coach and horses
through the very idea that is supposed
to underpin the UK the idea that the
Union is a partnership of eco Nations
and that brings in two very sharp relief
the second fundamental principle that I
believe we in Scotland can unite around
that Scotland's future must be in
Scotland's hands now I acknowledge that
not absolutely everyone who voted SNP
yesterday is ready to support
independence but the point of unity that
I do believe exists is this one whether
or not Scotland becomes an independent
country must be a matter for the people
who live here and let me stress for all
of us who live here no matter where we
come from it's not a decision for any
Westminster prime minister and certainly
not for one who suffered a crushing
defeat in Scotland last night the Tories
fought this campaign in Scotland on a
single issue they spoke quite literally
about nothing else they bombarded people
in Scotland with the same relentless
message day after day and night after
night they said that a vote for them was
a vote to deny people in Scotland the
right to decide our own future they said
it was a vote to reject an independence
referendum well yesterday the people of
Scotland decided instead to reject the
Tories the stunning election when last
night for the SNP renews reinforces and
strengthens the mandate we have from
previous elections to offer the people
of Scotland a choice over their future
the mandate says that it is for the
Scottish Parliament not a Westminster
government
to decide whether and when there should
be a new referendum on independence so
given the verdict of the people of
Scotland last night the Scottish
Government will next week publish the
detailed Democratic case for a transfer
of power to enable a referendum to be
put beyond legal challenge I have been
clear that a referendum must be the
responsibility of the Scottish
Parliament this is not about asking
Boris Johnson or any other Westminster
politician for permission it is instead
an assertion of the democratic rate of
the people of Scotland to determine our
own future given what I fear a Tory
government know has in store for
Scotland that right to choose our own
future has never been more important or
more argent so to the Prime Minister let
me be very clear this is not simply a
demand that I or the SNP are making it
is the rate of the people of Scotland
and you as the leader of a defeated
party in Scotland have no right to stand
in the way in an independent Scotland
you will always get the government's we
vote for we will have full control of
the powers and the levers needed to
build a truly fear and a more prosperous
country we can take our place as an
equal partner with our closest friends
and the rest of the UK and across Europe
and the world the people of Scotland
have spoken it is time now to decide our
own future thank you very much indeed
[Applause]